wie oder was geht ab hier soll kuranyi
und herzlich willkommen zum wohl meiner
meinung nach kosten minecraft spielmodus
den es jemals gab zusammen mit - tut
wir spielen heute unseren eigenen
spielmodus auf einem privaten server wir
vielleicht seht und wir spielen heute
lucky gestern ihr richtig gehört das ist
so viel wie get down mit lucky platten
also stadt kommen blöcken lucky blöcke
und danach sich trösten dass ihr je
gesehen hat mich richtig fertig wirklich
es wird richtig richtig cool es habe dir
was sagen wir gehen direkt rein franz
startete das spiel jetzt geht einfach
darum wer sammelt als erstes mal die
meisten lucky blöcke weil wir haben
einfach stadt köln blöcken ihr jetzt
wahrscheinlich einfach sehen sind die
teile da man kriegt dann pro pro block
den man erreicht los geht's kriegt man
ein lucky block ins emmental
und das zeigt ja schon dass du das ganze
ding wir müssen uns nach die sich bei
zwei bis vier typen einem coolen typen
betanken
ja und zwar diese beiden sind einmal ihr
seht schon her dass er gar keine keine
reguläre get down karte ja wir müssen
uns bedanken beim team
quantas dafür dass ihr uns diese coole
map und auch die coole deathmatch karte
communication später spielen werden und
bei colo dafür dass er dieses echt coole
plugin programmiert hat ja doch wer
arbeit also ich ja richtig dickes
dankeschön war wirklich würde ich weiß
nicht wer mir auf tour erfolgt können
übrigens alle machen wegen der
beschreibung dass wir das schon mal von
ganzen weile beziehungsweise dass ich
das schon vor einer ganzen weile
angekündigt habe heute kommt noch was
cooles warten lohnt sich oder so weil
wir da einfach dachten okay ist kein
bald losgehen wir sind mal fertig aber
es kommt immer und immer und immer
wieder was dazu und jetzt haben wir
endlich meine version die noch nicht
perfekt ist das sagen reicht aber reden
ja genau mit dem wir zufrieden sind und
die wir euch auf jeden fall zeigen
wollen ich bin ich gleich unten
ich habe schon gesehen weiß nicht wie du
so schnell sein konnten gleich ein
gestorben gut finde ich auf dem lucky
dog stehen muss man bekommt ja aber sagt
kurz bescheid bevor du auf das netzwerk
ist nämlich dass in der luft wenn wir
das
kleiner park leute mich wundern gibt
keine bugs tesch will muss das perfekt
läuft
es kann seine tränen kommen ist nicht
würdig glaube hier sterben leute zurück
sonst einen guten start und die unten
sind auch die box naisbitt mich noch
nicht auf der netz geben ich gehe jetzt
nach unten
euro stopp ja ok ok ich bin ich bin
unten
heute weiß ich bin und ich weiß ich weiß
wenn ich mir gesprochen kann noch nicht
absehen
ich habe zwölf alter schon mal sechs
stück mehr als ich du warst ja auch
wirklich weiter unten bei mir bekommen
hab einfach einen gelben kopf ich mache
das immer dass das hier so was hast du
dir zurück bekommen direkt junge was was
die unfair ist das wenn franz stück
nicht nur den verein stimmt nicht dass
wir in den ersten sachen habe ich einen
spieler kopf bekommt hab ich diamanten
risse bekommen und einen ganz bestimmten
posten einig sie lucky forschung nicht
die lucky porschen pflanzen vielleicht
ja gut bringst du erstmal eine hexe in
meinem bruder
ich glaube schon dass du tag machen
kannst hast du gemacht hast du mir
gemacht nicht mit absicht vergiftet
nicht schlagen ich mich schlank und mein
gott der mir eingerückt ich gehe es auch
nur 100 mit den ganzen bett los als ich
gebe noch ein bisschen brot habe ich
noch nie beim testen bekommen dieses so
geil junge was ist los mit dir
weil ich ich kann eigentlich jetzt gar
keine lucky box öffnen weil ich bin auf
dem halben herzen der mich würde alles
töten wenn ich bitten wem bist du
eigentlich [ __ ] ohr
nein das habe ich den fehler gemacht wo
alte was war das denn junge das ist das
ist einfach lucky blog wie es sein soll
die kann schon map eskaliert ist so ein
gigantisches loch
ich sehe da oben jemand alter ich hab
ihn nach oben bist du nur mal sicher zu
gehen kommt es war sommer klingt nicht
herunter ich hatte da einfach gerade zum
richtig schön wunder wunderschön dia
blog da oben und mit ok das ist
irgendwie recht gut aber aber ich wäre
aber noch ein bisschen zeit haben
du bist ja schon mal gut genug ist
ich hoffe jetzt aber dass du kannst es
ausgesprochen ernst
die etwas zu sagen aber für besten platz
1 ist ein diamanten privates nein ich
hatte selbst einen bessern die luft
gesprungen was wissen mit eiliger franz
ich wirklich schon so weiter also ja ich
will noch schwerer machen käfer spricht
mehr und ich haben lucky blogpost sich
auch noch lesen
ich hab' ich hab das was hinten in der
zwischenzeit machen kann
ich bin eh schon fertig also in fünf
minuten alles gut zu wissen
die rangelei einfach ein bisschen zeit
ich bin eigentlich so gut wie bereit
gleich in ein paar sekunden
ich bin echt gespannt was du so viel
zeug am start ist
ich bin ich mir noch nicht noch nicht
ganz bereit fans mein gott heute noch
kurz bleibt noch bis auf mich ja ich hab
wirklich geilste zeit bekommen was man
kriegen kann echt okay ich bin
eigentlich bereich ich noch nicht ganz
so deutlich muss noch kurz was checken
ich bin auch gleich voll gerecht aber
davor wie gesagt noch eine kurze sache
die ich klären muss ob die karte sieht
hier auch vielleicht aus leute okay na
gut ich gehe mal davon aus dass du
einfach keine großartigen level bekommen
hast du etwa leider auch nicht ich
wollte gern verzaubern aber mit den
apple bekommen
ich habe von irgendwas level bekomme ich
habe einige de france ich bin auch
bereit
was hast du da in der hand brot einfach
nur aus mit warum hast du den investoren
natürlich nicht haltbar ist und leute
lucky dog mlg könig okay die passion ich
werde dich rede kann auch kaum noch kaum
noch
das gibt's doch nicht
gibt es doch nicht da war einfach ein
verdammtes loch hatte den krass ich
hatte ich hatte so ein ist für ein
wächter für physik reaper und so weiter
alles auf aber ich hatte auch echt
cooles zeug hat nach den den zombie
getötet das bleibt sicherlich so ne
kranke op rüstung aber davor ich habe
dieses loch auch schon gesehen leute
dann ist es gerade hier
ich hatte selbst in der perle nein habe
ich mich sogar nach oben dran geworfen
aber ich hab nicht durch betroffen
unglaublich ärgerlich leute wenn ihr
noch mal so was sehen wollt was like
some kontraste story
ja noch mal so was sehen wollt dann
guckt erstmal bei franz vorbei und lasst
vor allem legal was macht ihr keinen
sinn aber das habe ich eine menge menge
arbeit und ich hoffe es hat euch
gefallen kommt auch bei den beiden teams
und beim entwickler verbreiteten richtig
richtig alle verlinkt und dann sehen wir
uns diesmal wieder mach zu tun bis dahin
tschüss